I think the media has reached an
all-time low in this country and I think
part of that is due to the embedding
process you know reporters embedded in
the front lines of troops in Iraq gives
you one perspective but what about
reporters embedded in hospitals and
Iraqi communities and the peace movement
around the world show the full
repercussions of war the true costs of
war and it's not only being embedded in
the front lines of troops it's being
embedded in the establishment he
interviewed Alistair sparks who is a
great south african journalists round
the ran Daily Mail will expose the
murder of Steve Biko the founder of the
Black Consciousness movement was named
by Nelson Mandela to be on the board of
the South African Broadcasting
Corporation and I was speaking to him in
Doha in Qatar and he was talking about
the role of the press in the United
States and how it always amazes him how
embedded the journalists are in the
United States and I think this all has
to be challenged as those reporters sit
in the White House press room and have
those press briefings there gaggles
every day I often refer to the access of
evil you know trading truth for access
in order to get that question directly
answered maybe by the Vice President or
the president you throw softball
questions at them and it's not worth it
you know these politicians need us much
more than we need them the access isn't
worth it and it's it really matters and
team were taught me this but so did many
stories all over the world and right
here at home that when the media acts as
a conveyor belt for lies I mean you look
at the lead-up to the invasion
and you look at what happened in this
country in 2003 this group called fair
fairness and accuracy and reporting here
based in New York did a study of the two
weeks around colon Powell giving his
push for war at the United Nations on
februari FF 2003 he was then Secretary
of State Fair looked at the four major
nightly newscasts at NBC ABC CBS and the
PBS newshour with jim lehrer there were
393 interviews done around war only
three were with anti war leaders three
of almost 400 that's no longer a
mainstream media that's an extreme media
that's a media beating the drums for war
because those who are opposed to war
those who are opposed to torture are not
a fringe minority not even a silent
majority but the silenced majority
silenced by the corporate media which is
why we have to take it back